this year's German Africa prize has been
awarded to two scientists to identify
the Omicron variant of the coronavirus
and Tulio de Oliveira are based in
Botswana and South Africa respectively
and have been praised for helping the
world better understand the pandemic and
respond swiftly we'll hear from them
right here in the studio in just a
moment but first DW correspondent Adrian
Krish visited their labs
the Botswana Harvard AIDS Institute is
one of the leading HIV research
institutions on the continent with some
of the best virologists including sikuli
moyo
when the pandemic hit moyo and his team
turned their focus from sequencing HIV
to covid
and in November 2021 they made an
unusual discovery
a new pattern with a high amount of
mutations the Omicron variant
they reported it immediately
[Music]
I think it presented a lot of potential
maybe
infections uh the only unfortunate
reaction was within a few hours a few
days that many countries in southern
Africa were blacklisted
almost two years into the pandemic the
world once again went on full alert
borders were closed flights to Southern
Africa canceled
and suddenly those who discovered it
became scapegoats even receiving death
threats a lot of people say you
scientists have big mouths look what you
have done and it was very uncomfortable
a few hours after it was discovered in
Botswana scientists here in South Africa
sequenced it too
Oliveira was one of moyo's PhD
supervisors now they closely collaborate
on their research
that's what this pandemic showed that
Africa can become a scientific leader on
on the pandemic response which surprised
many countries in the world but but did
not surprise us because that's big
Investments that we have been doing
especially in people but also in big
labs and equipment for the past 20 years
the Oliveira is one of the leading
scientists in the field of viral
outbreaks and is also from the global
South
what surprised him was how busy the
north was with itself during the
pandemic
an effective travel bands yeah so I
think that was very very very sad how
the world had a chance to respond to a
global problem and they decided to
respond with a nationalistic approach
which didn't help
despite these challenges moyo and
Oliveira continue their work proving
that leading medical research is also
done in Africa and that Europe can learn
lessons from the continent
joining me here in studio are Dr
sikhililia moyo and Professor Tulio de
Oliveira this year's recipients of the
German Africa prize welcome to DW and
congratulations on your achievements
um take us Dr Moyer to that moment when
you were in the lab and you realized you
were onto something
thank you for having us what an
incredible moment to contribute to the
world mid-november or special
during routine
sequencing of pathogens that we do on a
daily basis with experience from HIV for
many years we are used to looking at the
pathogen sequences to see if the
patterns are similar to what we have
seen before
so that mid-november was critical for us
we observed four sequences out of the 99
which generated that particular day they
were clustering away from others and
when we looked at them they had not seen
been seen anywhere else we thought it
was a mistake we worked on the lab we
looked at it and we contacted the
minister of Health we called it an
unusual lineage immediately after the
data came in we realized that this is a
cluster of individuals traveling
together and our sequences were really
showing that something that has not been
seen before and out of that of course
working with our colleagues we see that
the same pattern of mutations were seen
elsewhere within the region that showed
that something was going on and
immediately new cases started going on
Professor Oliveira did you at that time
realize how globally significant this
was
so so it happened in the same day we
also saw a eight genomes in South Africa
we contact each other we worked together
for for for a decade yeah and that time
then what we have to do we have to call
like an urgent meeting and we call all
the main big labs in South Africa and
then we identify where was the source of
infections and then we do this very fast
sample transport 100 samples from 100
different clinics come to our lab and we
start producing genomes in very fast and
around time we are talking about hours
by then so less than a day after we were
sure that this was not unusual cases
we're not just a little cluster but was
something completely widespread and then
it's my job as the head of the network
to communicate with the government and
that normally for talking to the health
minister to the minister of Science and
Innovation and they decided that we
should cover urgent meeting with our
president president Cyril ramaphosa who
will give clear direction that he could
really see a big pattern emerging there
and that we should go public and that
and that's how we think days of
identifying the first cases and using a
very Advanced Network that was
constructed during Decades of investment
infectious disease we could characterize
in record time the the what potentially
the most important variant in the
pandemic and Dr Moyer to come back to
you this was an important moment for
collaboration
um it was this something that had been
normal in in your sector or did the
pandemic sort of bring your work
together across across the different
Labs across the different borders this
actually highlighted years of work that
we have done in HIV in working together
with our colleagues within Botswana and
South Africa especially with a Tulio
Professor tulio's group that we've been
looking at mutations of TB HIV and other
infections so this was a platform that
allowed us to respond very quickly but
professor as soon as you've achieved
this this significant moment there was
Swift travel bans on African countries
there were also some people locally who
were you know blaming you you for uh for
disrupting their travel their holiday
travel plans did you feel that this
detracted from your achievement so so
that following days were quite hard yeah
we because the travel ban which was
absolute unnecessarily and even an
ethical we got many at that threats we
end up have to work and I'm Security in
our lab but but but but we persevere
yeah we were protected at very high
level by our own President coming public
and highlighting that that this is not
the fault of the scientists and what
became quite clear is that the Omicron
spread everywhere and I believe it
caused a massive a wave of infection
Germany for example even despite the
travel ban and what's become very clear
is that Omicron is not even come from
Southern Africa it's just that we have
invested for decades hundreds of
millions of dollars to construct some of
the most advanced infectious disease
program in the world and do you think
then that this is is proof of what
African medical research can do can
offer the world from from what you were
able to do in the labs yes of course and
and and and now after the the word
learning that we should not punish
individuals and countries for discover
of pathogens they begin to come together
and that's why we are here we we have
spent a week in Germany now we just met
with the chancellor he had to receive
award and that's what we are saying if
we work together with the world and
build on the big investment and
scientific infrastructure and knowledge
that existing Africa we can really help
the world to become a safer place and I
hope the world learn from the mistakes
and instead of now yeah yeah blaming and
punishing for discoveries that we
support and encourage that okay and we
see as well as strong partnership that
we've met so many people this week in
Germany that they could learn from what
Africa is doing especially in infectious
diseases and we can learn from the high
technology and innovations that Germany
as scientists have have developed okay
we'll have to leave it there Dr moyo and
Dr Professor Tulia de Oliveira
congratulations again and thank you for
speaking to us thank you thank you